[موسيقى]
السلام السلام
[تصفيق]
عليكم طيب atop is a pharmacological
extract used m
asin agent that works primar on mascar
receptors of the
neurotransmitter which chief mediates
paric
sy all for phys
examination طيب في كم زول حضر فيلم للمره
الثانيه واستمتع
ب طيب الفر شن ليه
الاكشنور لا نسال ليه
اصلا الهدف من الاكشن يا شباب
[موسيقى]
انه
طيب يعني انت تحفظ الحاجه
وتتذكر ن لكل واحده
فيش هي
معناها
يعني تتذكر قدر شنو الحاجه
دي للاحساس اللي كنت مرب وانت بتحضر في
تجربه يعني لو كنت خايف شديد لو كنت مبسوط
شديد لو كنت مستمتع بال بتعمل فيه انت
ماتنساه في الحرب العالميه
التانيه
انتهت لما استعملت اول اتومك بومب على
هيروشيما وناجازاكي في
اليابان في زول عارف بيحصل شنو
وين اللي بحصل اول حاجه بيطلع
ديشن بكميات مرعبه النتيجه بتاعتها انه اي
حاجه ثيرمال راديشن بتبقى بخار بتتبخر
المباني الناس كلهم اللي كانوا قريبين من
مكان النيشن
تبخروا عوائل
واهل والي ما ماتوا
كده
اتحرقوا والل ما اتحرقوا شافوا اهلهم
بيتحرقوا الماساه كانت انه الفضل عايشين
السخانه كانت انبير لدرجه كله على الريفز
والجداول عشان يبردوا جسمهم
شويه الماساه انه الريفز دي ذاتها المويه
بتاعتها كانت الموست بتغلي من السخانه فما
فادتهم ما بس
كده العطش كان ما معقول الناس دي ما ح
تقدر تشرب المويه السخنه متذكرين الناس
اللي تبخروا والمباني اللي
تبخرت الحاجات دي كونت سحب سودا ونزل مطر
اسود والناس اضطرت
تشربه ناس شربوا اهلهم شربوا
بيوتهم التجربه دي كل اللي حضروها من
نسوها تجربه دي تعلمنا منها كلنا انه
الحرب دي حاجه ما مفروض نعملها
تاني انا متاكد لو كانت دي حصه تاريخ انتم
مستعدين تسمعوها ساعه ان لقدام صح الفريق
شنو
طيب الفرق في الستوري تين الكشر والموفي
الاثنين دايرين يوصل لك معلومه بتبدا بسم
اي بتبني فوق بعض عان تعمل
مور ونصل في النهايه ل كونكلوجن في نهايه
الكشر في نهايه الفيلم بنتعلم حاجه بنطلع
بمعلومه انا في بدايه
الكلام سالت سؤال قلت لكم شنو اللي بيحصل
وين اتومك بومب
ديت يعني اللحظه انت بتسمع فيها
سؤال مخك بيحاول يلقط كل المعلومات اللي
لها علاقه بالسؤال سالوك ليه عشان يطلع
اجابه طيب لو احنا بنحب الاسئله كده ليه
لما يسالو في محاضره ما في زول بجاوب كم
واحد فينا مره
بتجربه الكشر سال سؤال واول ما جاوب انت
قلت هسه كنت ح جاوبه ليه ما
جاوبنا ما جاوبنا عشان احنا عارفين انه
الجواب اللي في راسنا زنبل ممكن ندافع عنه
لكن ما عارفين اذا هو الجواب
الصح صح يعني شنو في الاديوكيشن سيستمز ال
هسه
شغاله لما الكشر يسال سؤال ما بكون عايز
له اجابه بيكون عايز الاجابه الهسه
عندنا ولو تعلمنا حاجه من الساينس حاجه ذ
كيبس ريتين اوفر ان اوفر هي انه الاجوبه
اللي عندنا هسه ما بالضروره هي الاجوبه
الصح طيب تخيلوا معاي اديكيشن سيستم كان
فيو لو الزول يسالوه سؤال منفكر في اجابته
على انها صح ولا غلط فكر
علنا لو سالناك سؤال وجاوبت جوابك نقولك
دافع عنه ليه جاوبت جواب
زيده الحاجه الثانيه خلت القصه حكينا ديست
هي حاجه
اسمها لما زول يوصف له حاجه بتفاصيل دقيقه
بشوفها
قدامه كلنا شفنا الناس دي بتتعذب وكلنا
حسينا
بجهم
البروسس الثانيه
ريكول يك يعني
يعني الحاجه دي على انت عندك كم كيورد كم
كم اسوسيشن
يوصلك ل كم واحد فينا شم ريحه ولا سمع
اغنيه قديمه وتذكر حاجات في حياته ما كان
متذكره قبل كده الحاجه دي حصلت عشان
الاسوس
شنز
طيب لما واحد فينا يمشي لدكتور عيون في
حاجه اسمها فندو سكوبي هي لايت وعدسه
بعاين بها دكتور جو عينك يشوف الحاصل
شنو المشكله انه لما تنور نور في عين
انسان البوبلي
بيضيق طيب كده احنا ما حنشوف الحاصل شنو
جو
الحل شنو الحل انه دكتور بيستعمل لك قطره
اسمها
اتروبين القطره
دي بنطلعها من نبات عائله بتاع نباتات
اسمها نايت شيد ظل المساء الحاجه دي
جواها في نباتات كثيره احنا بنستعملها
فيها البطاطس فيها الطماطم فيها التوباكو
وفيها نبته اسمها ددلي نايت ظل الليل
المميت اسمه رهيب
صح عشان
نعرف اسمه العلمي اتروبا
بلادونا عشان نفهم الكلام ده معناه شنو
حسافر شويه حنمشي ايطاليا بلادونا دي
بالايطالي معناها بييف و ليه اسمها كده
لانه زمان كان البنات الايطاليات بيجيبوا
النبات ده بينشفه بيحنو بينقع وبيشيل
المويه خطوها في قطرات صغيره اي واحده وهي
طالعه الصباح تنقط نقطه في العين دي نقطه
في العين
دي البؤبؤ بيبقى اسود وكبير مع الازرق
والاخضر اللي
ورا بيعمل
شغب
ف دي بلادونا طيب اتروبا دي
شنو حنطر عشان نفهم اتروبا نسافر اليونان
هناك في الجريك ميثولوجي الاساطير الرقيه
زيوس و هيركوليس والناس الرهيبين دي في
المسؤولين عن الفيت اوف من قدر الرجال
ثلاثه
بنات الاولى فيهم بتطلع خيط من البكره
بتديه للثانيه الثانيه بتخيط ولما تخلص
بتديها للثالثه عشان تقطع انا قبيل قلت
لكم اسمه ديدلي نايت شيد لكن ما جاوبنا
ليه اسمه
كده اسمه كده عشان زمان كان بيجيبوا
النبات ده بينشفه بيحنو بينقع وبيشيل
المويه بتاعته يخطوها في الاكل احنا كلنا
عارفين انه اي ماده لو اخذت منها اوفردوز
حتت
سمم
بقوم الناس بعد ما تاكل الاكل وتتبسط
بتموت متذكرين الثلاثه بنات الاولى اللي
بتطلع الخيط
دي الثانيه بتحيك احداث حياته والثالثه
لما تنتهي بتقتله الثالثه دي اسمها اتس
ومنها طلعنا
اتين الكلام دهو كان قرك انا متاكد ان ما
حنساه والكلام اللي ه شرحناه دهن
المط
طيب كده احنا عارفين كيف نخلي الناس تمتع
الحاجه
طيب شن السقف بسموه في السيكولوجي حاجه
اسمها
ف الكلمه دي بعملوها ناس
كتستعمل لما يتكلم
عنفور استعملوها
الونا
الفلو دي ستيت بتحس بها لما تكون انت
مستمتع بال بتعمل فيه لما
تكون الحاجه بتحصل لما يكون في بالنس بين
التشالنج المقدمه لك والسك اللي
عندك
لازم التشالنج وال سكيل الاثنين
يكونوا تكون خطير في بتعمل فيه وتكون عارف
ان الناس تتكيف لما تشوفك بتعم بيخلينا
نتفرج لانه لانه الناس رهيبه واحنا مدمنين
على الاحساس
ده مكن تحسب في خرافي من
اندرش
[موسيقى]
لحد
الحاجه
دي اي زول خلى حاجه رهيبه
بوراه خلاها وهو ان فلو ستيت كلنا سمعنا
بماي انجلو
افترض الزول ده في مره من
المرات طلبوا منه تبينت حيط وسقف كاثيدرال
كامله التشالنج
خطير لكن كلنا عارفين انه مايكل انجلو
قدره وهو ذاته عارف انه
قدره الزول ده لما بدا يرسم قالوا دخل
الفرشه رسم ورسم ورسم لا اكل لا شرب لا
نام الزول ده نس نفسه في اللي بيعمل فيه
لحد ما كانسز اوت بغمر وصحوه وبيصحى نشيط
ويرجع يرسم اني زول ده في
اسبوعين عمل
ده طيب لو احنا عملنا سيستم بتاع اديكيشن
فيه بروف تالنز كل مره تحدوك تحدي اكبر
وبوك انك شغال رهيب بالطريقه دي احنا
هنسهل على الستيودنت انهم يخشوا فلو حنعمل
ناس ناس ما بس
كان
[تصفيق]
شكرا